The girl behind me is of this type, but it's
nice. I also go on dates and live in Shonan.
Why is this crazy situation all of a sudden?
Sumi-chan and the sea, and the sweet
sound of being friends. I have such a
cute friend, and I'm
worried.  The sea is really good for me, and that's really all there is to it.My
brain is in wolf mode again, and when I
say I'm worried about going to the sea, it's like this.But I can't have a
conversation.Well, it's already
private, so I can't force myself to talk.
Isn't it?
Match
Match Two people face each other, hold out both index fingers, and
play a hand game where you increase the number of fingers.By
touching the other person's finger with your finger, you can add that finger to the other person.Repeat
this alternately until both hands
exceed 5.  But everyone is big,
so you know that. The
sound of the ride keeps looking up ways to kill time. Go
ahead. I don't know what to do if you come.  I
'm glad it looked like it was fun. In
this kind world,
life isn't just about talking.
Summary of mysteries